let's get to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 people very eager to get their
thoughts and a lot has happened in the
last week politically will go first to
our caller from the 2 6 7 area code
callers listen for your phone number for
your area code you will not hear like a
beep or anything like that you'll just
be on let's go to our caller from 267
who's this
hi David can you hear me all right yeah
go ahead who's this this is Connor from
Penn State again great go ahead
I just wanted to one ask you a question
but first I wanted to give like a
message to fellow progressives to not
really be so short-sighted when it comes
to like the gun issue whereas like from
what I've seen in the last couple days
everyone's been focusing on like the
school shooting as opposed to the mass
shooting at large yeah whereas like
though a lot of conservatives seem to be
focusing on like oh like let's hear
armed guards here and there but a lot of
these mass shootings don't seem to be
happening in necessarily schools of
course so like when when it happened in
like say a movie theater do we want
armed guards everywhere basically I
don't say so I just want to say like to
fellow progressives like don't let them
don't like conservatives or like don't
advocate necessarily try to trick you
into being short-sighted all right we
should have like a much law what's your
question today Connors we got a bunch of
people here hello Mike yeah I'm sorry my
question is basically I know there's no
silver bullet but when it comes to
ranking how to solve the gun issue what
do you think is the number one thing
that progressives should be advocating
for or against okay so listen here's the
thing
I would not each each change that could
be made to deal with the gun issue is
going to attack a different area of the
problem so I wouldn't necessarily know
how to rank them what I do think from a
political strategy point of view is go
for what's most popular politically
right now at the top of that list would
be 100% universal background checks
right politically that's the most
popular one nationwide followed by
some of the specific high-capacity
magazine bans or maybe certain types of
firearms but but right now politically
speaking background checks is the most
popular so I might at least start with
that although again not any nut none of
these individual ideas is going to solve
every aspect of the problem or even
close to it yeah I completely agree do
you think that we should be tying more
the mental health care as well to like
because like the conservative state seem
to be the ones that lack Medicaid
funding and stuff like that yeah you
know I've talked about that meant the
mental illness issue is a big one but we
have to make sure that we don't allow
the right to make the focus just mental
health so that that's an important Conor
thank you really appreciate the call